I think what I'll do is I'll join the
tournaments mmm it's too rapid and I
won't desert I'm not gonna try and win
it I just want to play some like decent
games yeah I'll try and try and be
instructive trying have some quality
chess
Logan either is first and saying first
that's that's a rarity in Sahaj is
second hello
welcome people pebbles man same King
also known as Big Daddy I don't know if
I'll be using this extension I was
actually thinking about having like um
channel point redemptions to change to
basically change the words within the
extension it would take some work to set
up but just an idea anyway okay playing
the hourly rapid arena hello to everyone
if you're just joining you are joining
on time this elephant spelled wrong hell
oh it didn't stay from last time I
thought I fixed it
thanks for that all right
it's a sealian time it's 147 in Portugal
well good morning or good yeah good good
evening good night I don't know if
you're gonna go to sleep or stick around
but you have to stick around for at
least one game also nor converting from
a twitch prime to a Tier one thanks so
much
nor welcome back so d 3d three signifies
that White's going for some probably
closed Sicilian maybe some Kings Indian
settle for
so with f4 so early I'm inclined I'm
inclined to go for a d5 I think I'll
start with you six and then then go for
d5 this is a slightly unusual move order
but looks playable play some gambits
it's hard to gambit from this this sort
of opening only White's playing very
solidly probably in future games but
this will be this will probably be
positional if white plays a five we'll
have some kind of French structure night
a3 very very weird-looking move the
first thing that comes to mind is takes
takes take away White's castling rights
huh I give away the c-4 square I play
that your boy deploy in all London
themes tournament Oh welcome back I
barely know the rules
thanks for something yeah I'm trying to
figure out what to do here I should not
take so much time in this position I'm
realizing that takes takes we trade
Queens it's not so damaging to white so
I think I'll just plain out of six
I'll pressure the pawn if this this just
want to create a situation where the
knight is feeling left out
and and win them something at Tier one
thanks so much
okay now it's a free pawn yeah opponent
did not respond to my threat
so all of my opponents ratings are
provisional interesting
nyeeehhh 595 is interesting because if I
take take
then my knight has to move and I lose a
pack of pawn and I don't really want to
allow this I think I'll play 94 just hit
the bishop
if takes I'll take back and then the
Knights will be occupying the center
yeah I change I change the channel point
redemptions a little bit I learned I
learned some lesson from the last stream
I want to be mindful didn't fare for
most of the stream I do have my mind
folding so if anyone has 1.5 million
channel points oh oh that's a good move
oh wow that's a really good move finally
caught up screaming the game bit a
minute welcome back wait I have to take
this seriously
there should be five because I I take it
it runs in two takes takes takes I lose
a rook be down the exchange that might
be playable though let's calculate takes
takes takes I'll soon take skinny eight
takes I can take on a three takes and
then something something along the lines
of g6 Bishop g7 except there's Bishop b2
in that line the alternative is to play
King Assad on which looks terrible but I
have to choose between some evils
also realizing like could um so in this
line after takes takes takes why could
take back on b5 it's not easy to defend
this pawn I guess I have kini 7 whatever
I do here I'm gonna have to suffer some
some ugliness okay so it takes let's
calculate a bit more precisely
so imagine light goes into this line the
King will go to e8 maybe just 96 mm that
that line but taking looks nice takes
takes yeah the lights going to be
trapped oh I love it too yeah I'll keep
it in mind
thanks for summing she busts yes go
welcome back something for eight months
yeah so some black or white has a
pleasant choice Here I am temporarily up
a minor piece so it has it was a
decision to make it takes on b5 okay um
I'm actually still up upon Salt Lake
Heaney 7 it's a really ugly move the
Queen's are off the board so there's no
there's no meat I'm ready to untangle
with some pawn moves I do occasionally
run into the h3 line in the Budapest
Tommy not too often but it's a decent
position aligned for whites okay so now
my Knights tied down to the pawn if I
plated this that's probably only helping
white B sixes looks like a solid move a
six also
white might have a threat of this have
to be careful alright let's start with
ff69 here I'll play d6 at this point is
just about consolidating completing
development yeah probably still be six
some idea of vision a six it would
require some calculation it's still a
bit of a mess
OT time DAC receiving or redeeming 999 9
alright
tea time a4 interesting move if we're
slightly annoying because a5 is gonna be
strong
hmm okay so I'm trying to calculate the
Slaton after revision basics 97 takes
takes and the question is can I drop the
night King d7 actually looks promising
what can come to d1 King c8 let's do it
I'm also preventing a 5 a strange game
so far if I get the chance all yeah play
rook she 96 is now I'll playable move so
I could take takes rook d8 yeah and
trades should be should be beneficial
for me I don't think White has another
option and then well I'm looking at his
takes takes rook d1 King c7 and then
I'll have I'll have some 96 for Bishop
d6 whoa it's around power chicken well
it's not found for our chicken
thanks for raining shoutouts to the
vampire if you're just joining this is
my first game of the stream I stopped by
vampire stream earlier was having a
London themed tournament okay I can't
get to Mullen time because there's no
increment reading points are on the line
I do have this move it looks passive
about it if I can trade that's what life
is all about at least when you're up
material
yeah shut did I give a shout-out I did
okay the link is in the chat people
should follow the vampire I'll be
uploading a YouTube video tomorrow where
I I specifically mentioned the vampire I
do give a shout outs to vampire in the
youtube description it'll be a video
about the the joys of the NAT mincing
gambit which I've been trying to learn
more about it
maybe we'll see maybe we'll see
enactments in this stream ooh that's a
good move to play this I don't know what
I'm gonna do about this move cuz I could
repeat but I don't want to draw if I get
like one tempo this is tricky
I might have to sack a pawn which is not
what I want to do okay this is this is
very nice like wait should have played
this but now the rooks gonna come in I'm
realizing it's actually still not easy
wow I forgot now this pawn is weak
alright I have to have to defend this
pawn I'm gonna lose a pawn yeah this
pawns falling question is how bad is it
at least White's taking time oh maybe
it's not so bad because I have mmm no it
doesn't I still might end up playing
this yeah likes playing this well okay
so I'll play that's really not what I
want to do I do have a five takes in an
f5 yeah let's do that
and now I'll try and treat this pawn as
a weakness like if I can can get to te
six it shouldn't be so bad if the pawn
goes a six then then it should be
attackable I'll have this set up ideally
with a king coming in as well yeah why
it's playing a good game despite the
unusual opening oh thanks messy Marvin
slumming at Tier one for for 23 months
thanks so much
almost two years appreciate that I
really got to make up time gort's double
underscore thanks for solving with Prime
I like the facts my opponents thinking
because it's not so clear what white
wants to do my pawns are are all quite
solid this Bishop is very restricted
like if the bishop is not happy just
staring at my immaculate Queen side pawn
chain mmm alright let's control the only
open file
I changed my mind from the original idea
of putting the rook here especially now
that the square is open o g4 might be
coming if it happens all try and deal
with it
g4 Wow okay so I can play this I'm
definitely worse here like objectively
it's not pleasant I don't want to trade
rooks look T it was probably probably
the wrong decision 50 rating points
today mmm ouch that's life though that's
the nature of online chess too when you
play a lot a rating can fluctuates in
both directions
okay considering a six play a six
because otherwise upon was just just a
long-term target the downside with a six
is my cue what does this move Wow
I was a nifty move
Wow so the thread is this if I play this
and I lose I play this I have to try
this
why explaining this really well so I'm
calculating rook g7 takes takes and then
King AIDS
interesting yeah likes preserving cause
yeah
strong decision
okay let's try this idea Bishop here
very possible I'll end up sacking like a
lotta pawns yeah Brooke g1 who's really
strong and nice I couldn't afford to
allow this a mess
it's so complicated so I still have hope
so my plan is after it takes to play
King here I'll be attacking this and
then it should be a weakness as well
doesn't look promising though thrusday 3
p.m. Central Time and be there this is
really unpleasant but ok at least this
pawn is a weak idea Bishop d6 there's
some hope with time too
even though time is very much dwindling
I forgot we could play that right away
thankfully I'm still controlling the
rink it was very risky though I'm a BB 5
c4 I just want to slow light down now
it's so simple how white makes progress
either maybe that's how okay the pawns
defended maybe this move
have to take all right it's completely
losing but I'm hopeful I am hopeful
because white doesn't know what to do
it's not easy for a white to improve
upon time - yeah so here oh well good
move that let's play off three oh wow
oh I am losing I miss that a I have to
go for this my pone slow am I am I gonna
win on time
oh they're lagging it's a draw
No Oh Nathan one I want had made in one
well how well you play that really well
hi mr. Acuff aids I don't know if I can
stop it anyway though maybe King I
should play King b7 here so I lost some
rating points wait I want to go over
that game it's very lucky my opponent
was very slow and like had I mean quite
could pre move to victory yeah like I'm
just completely lost but okay King b7
Bishop c5
I got I got played like a pawn - um I
thought white was gonna go for a draw it
like go for this repetition line but I
wasn't so clear
g4 yeah this whole concept with the rook
have one in g4 man didn't move times
yeah the move times are slightly
suspicious
yeah also like unless my poems like
anonymous Geum
this is this is a pretty clear sign of
engine analysis I usually don't like to
make that like public statements like
this but yeah I did have the feeling
during the game especially with like
amount of time
why was was playing with my survives I
did survive yeah well I had no clue how
to like finish off a game except yes I
was thankful to to move quickly enough
anyway that's unfortunate it's
discouraging too cuz in general I I do
enjoy playing like the slower games but
yeah I mean I could just play again
stockfish if I want if I want a tough
challenge I didn't win now the it was a
draw officially because I didn't have
any meeting material when you win on
time but you only have your king left
it's a draw but it's not like I'm
playing trying to win the tournament I
mentioned this at the start of a stream
I'm just trying to play to have
interesting games a university has a
chess tournament any advice or opening
recommendations most of your games won't
be determined in the opening so don't
worry too much about like specific
openings especially at a certain level
it's hard to like even if you study
openings it's hard to like get exactly
what you studying so definitely like
understand principles and then be like
usually before tournament you want to be
very tactically sharp so most your time
right before the tournament you should
prioritize solving tactics and
prioritize just getting enough rest and
don't burn yourself out
I do report yeah I do report cheaters
usually not on stream though not worth
the time